if you'd like to support more content on
the channel and get some epic anime
merch check out our online store anime
out Broadcom we have original designs
that were done exclusively for us by pro
manga artist Cuusoo mati
including this dream big work hard hasta
shirt for your fan of the channel feel
free to use the discount code uproar 25
at checkout for an instant 25 percent
off
[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and today we will be
talking about the massive twists and
turns in the recent chapters of the
black clover manga that have completely
changed the game as far as the story
goes
shocking mysteries about characters
we've known from the very beginning have
just been revealed and characters we
thought were long dead are back and
ready to do battle against the ultimate
evil I definitely wasn't prepared for
this and I can safely say that the
recent events in the manga have changed
everything we thought we knew about the
world of black clover if you enjoyed the
black clover content on this channel you
want to see more you can leave a like to
let me know and if you're new to anime
or don't forget to subscribe and hit
that notification bell just a quick
warning because we are talking about the
latest developments in the story this
video will contain manga spoilers so
proceed with caution
you have been warned as if we didn't
know this already
the latest chapters have once again
emphasize how incredibly overpowered the
devil is the devil has the ability to
use magic that devours mana and life
energy this Devil magic has the ability
to consume magical attacks and render
opponents essentially powerless and even
Yami and the elf and Charlotte's body as
insanely strong as they are are unable
to stand against the devil's dark power
thankfully hasta is the only one who is
able to withstand the devil magic his
lack of magic makes it pointless for the
devil magic to try and devour him and
using his anti magic sword
hasta is able to break through the devil
magic
I wonder if Austin's resistance to this
devil magic is also related to the demon
inside his grimoire or whether his own
lack of magic is the only reason why he
is able to resist at any rate I am
fascinated to find out more about this
otherworldly dark magic and Auster's
ability to withstand it but this new
reveal about the devil magic is just the
beginning of the shocking twists and
turns that the story has just given us
we recently learned a Nero the anti bird
that has been following hasta ever since
the magic Knights engines exam is
actually a girl
I am NOT going to say a human girl
because the race / species she belongs
to is not yet clear but I will get back
to the question of what exactly Nero is
later on in this video it turns out that
Nero was a girl who was sealed inside
the body of an anti bird at the same
time that the first wizard King was
sealed inside the stone statue of
himself that rests atop the giant demons
skull near hog a village we recently
learned that Nero was able to speak in
her bird form and using this ability to
speak she convinces FINRA to transport
them back to the statue of the first
wizard King there she uses the magic
stones to awaken the first wizard King
once again and we learned that Nero was
the one who used confinement magic to
seal the first wizard king inside the
statue when he was on the verge of death
500 years ago once the first wizard
Kings seal is broken and the stone
statue comes to life
Nero seal is also broken and her true
humanoid form is revealed as the statue
of the first wizard King comes to life
Nero refers to him as her prince and the
wizard Kings has to Finn rule that now
that the seal has been broken using the
magic stones he has awakened once again
although not completely I'm not sure
what exactly he means when he says that
he is not awakened completely but it is
clear that already in this state the
first wizard King is incredibly powerful
and his magic is apparently even greater
than the magic of the elves as soon as
the first wizard King awakens even
though he is awakened only partially he
can sense the devil's magic right away a
magic that is not of this world
the wizard King knows instantly that the
devil has acquired a body so it is clear
from this that the first wizard King
knows a lot about the devil
and the nature of his power in fact it
is clear to me that the first wizard
king and Nero decided to seal the wizard
King inside the statue so that he could
be awakened again when the devil made
his next move
clearly Nero the first wizard King and
probably Licht knew that their showdown
with the devil 500 years ago wasn't the
end of the battle they knew that the
devil would return and they made a
secret plan to face him once he did
return earlier in the story the devil
already told us that 500 years ago his
plan to acquire a body and become fully
incarnate
into this world was foiled by licked and
the first wizard King although he didn't
tell us how exactly they manage to foil
him he also didn't tell us anything
about Nero although it now seems
undeniable that she must have played a
major role in stopping the devil from
achieving his ultimate goal five
centuries earlier
Nero's very existence proves that the
story about the heroic first wizard king
destroying the giant demon God the story
that we were all told at the beginning
of every anime episode and the story
that all the humans and clover kingdom
learned as children is clearly
incomplete if not outright inaccurate
the first wizard King didn't just
destroy the giant demon God creature and
then they all lived happily ever after
we now know that the first was er King
himself was on the verge of death and he
was saved from death by Nero because she
sealed him inside the statue it seems to
me that the wizard king and Nero knew
that the devil will probably come back
some time in the future so they had to
form a secret plan to undo the seal and
reawaken the first wizard King once the
devil appeared again knowing what we
know now about Nero the birds behavior
throughout the series starts to make
perfect sense this whole time Nero has
been searching for magic stones in order
to break the first wizard King seal
while she was still in her bird form she
chose to hang around hasta in particular
and she constantly guides Austen and his
comrades ensuring that they stay on the
right path we know Nero could sense
magic including ancient magic and she
makes sure that Aust and the others find
the magic stones think all the way back
to so she village when Nero finds the
stone in the village church or to the
seabed temple when Nero again finds the
magic stone or to the witch queen and
how Nero recognizes that there is a
magic stone in her earring and the witch
queen also seems to actually recognize
Nero so all this time Nero has had a
secret plan to locate and collect the
magic stones and use them to awaken the
first wizard King and regain her true
form in the process we just had no idea
what she was really up to until now not
to mention that we now finally know why
Nero kept pecking at Asta's head all the
time even though she was clearly fond of
him and liked to hang around him
she is just your classic bird girl
assume that it and this brings us to the
next big question what exactly is
Nero she doesn't appear to be there a
human or an elf and in fact she appears
to have dark horns on her head just like
the demons when talking to Finn Rahl she
says that she has been called Nero by
quote your people and quote implying
that she is not part of his people or
maybe even people in general could Nero
be a member of a mysterious demon /
devil race the same species as the devil
and the demon inside Asta's grimoire if
she is a team and why does Nero look
much more human than the other demons
and why is she supporting the first
wizard King and calling him her Prince
instead of supporting say the devil
could Nero be a hybrid a member of the
demon race and another race like human
or elf
we now know that Charmy is a human dwarf
hybrid so it is possible that Nero is
some sort of hybrid as well or she could
be a member of another race altogether
but I think that having those dark horns
on her head just like the demon seems
like a bit too much of a coincidence to
me at any rate I am extremely interested
to find out more about Nero and if she
is a demon or part demon I can't wait to
find out why she would be loyal to a
human like the first wizard King instead
of being loyal to members of her own
species another big question that we
have to consider is why Nero chose to
follow hasta in particular was she just
attracted to his lack of magic like the
other anti birds or was she able to
sense the demon inside of Oscar's
grimoire we know that the devil could
sense that there was another devil /
demon inside of us as grimoires so if we
assume that Nero is also a demon or part
demon she could have potentially sensed
the other demon inside the grimoire as
well I believe the Nero might have
chosen hasta because he has an important
role to play in the secret plan that she
the wizard king and probably lik came up
with 500 years ago they knew that the
devil would eventually return they knew
that he would someday make his move and
Asta's lack of magic and his ability to
use Lix old grimoire could be a key part
of their plan to ultimately defeat the
devil we've already seen that hasta is
the only one who is able to resist and
overcome devil magic so it's pretty
clear that his unique abilities will
play a major role but then the question
is how could the first wizard king and
Nero possibly know about ah stuff 500
years before he was even born how could
someone was born 5 centuries after the
first wizard King was
sealed inside the statue possibly fit
into the first wizard Kings secret plan
it could be that it isn't Austin
particular De Niro was looking for she
was just looking for anyone that could
handle the 5-leaf grimoire but it could
also be that there is more to Austin and
his mysterious origins than we even
realized in a previous theory video I
suggested that Austin you know could be
the reincarnation of the first wizard
King and licked respectively
I argued that because they knew that the
devil would at some point return the
first wizard King in licked used some
form of reincarnation magic to ensure
that they would also return when the
devil returns so that they could finally
defeat him once and for all I will leave
a link to that video in the description
in case you guys want to check it out
because that's where I laid out the
theory in great detail I don't want to
repeat it all here but now do we know
that the first wizard King was actually
sealed away inside the stone statue it
doesn't seem like Aastha could be his
reincarnation even though there are many
similarities between Austin and the
first wizard King both in terms of
appearance and in terms of personality
however I find one piece of information
extremely interesting once his seal is
broken the first wizard king states that
he has only partially awoken he is not
completely awake similarly the
reincarnation of lifts is awake in an
artificial body but this reincarnation
is clearly not the same person as the
leader of the elves from five hundred
years ago the artificial lift has a much
colder and more robotic personality than
the original as if he also isn't fully
awake just like the first wizard King so
could it be the licked and the first
wizard king are still incomplete because
they used some mysterious spell which
ensured that a part of them would one
day be reincarnated into humans and
those humans are you know and Austin
this would mean that you know in hasta
are not outright reincarnations of lick
than the first was a king but some part
of licked and the first wizard king is
currently inside you know and pasta and
this is why the two of them have so many
similarities both in terms of
personality and physical appearance to
lift and the first wizard king and so
the real reason why lift and the first
wizard king are not fully awake in the
present is that some part of them is
actually residing inside you know
and hasta now this would definitely
explain why Nero chose to follow hasta
in particular but this is all just
friendly speculation at this point and I
can't wait to find out more as the story
continues let me know what you guys
think what kind of creature is Nero is
she a demon a hybrid or something else
altogether
also what do you think is the connection
between Nero the first wizard King and
hasta and how do you think Nero's secret
plan will ultimately unfold let me know
down in the comments I always love
hearing from you if you enjoyed this
video and you want to see more you can
leave a like to let me know and if
you're new to anime uproar definitely
don't forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell a huge thank you to
all of our anime uproar patrons for
supporting our work and when I
especially thank our pro hero tier
patrons the one and only Gilgamesh
keelon and chubs is the man and another
huge thank you to our the one to your
patrons the ones who stand above all
other clans including ace Matty Mac
James a lowland Adam baby ray Ingrid ah
and a mod if you guys feel that our
content provides value for you and you
want to support more be sure to check
out our patreon link in the description
even donating a single dollar will give
you access to our anime up for patron
exclusive discord and your name will
appear in our videos along with these
amazing people as always thank you guys
so much for watching I really appreciate
it and until next time see us space
cowboys
[Music]